What's you got a follow-up question?
Yeah. Um I mean I've been reading uh the
old test this is the next question.
Thank you for that question. Yeah
answer. Uh this is the next uh question.
All right. The the um the the uh in the
old testament the is the Israelites were
fighting a lot of um like over and over
the bible keep mentioning that the
Israelites were fighting giants. I know
I don't want I don't get into the
nephilim numbers 133133 verse 33 it says
that there were giants Nephilim the sons
of Anak what about them yeah but it
didn't even stop there like even in in
judges and it's all over the Old
Testament where you talk about the
Israelites these guys were like they
were like grasshoppers amongst Is that
hyperbole or is that literal is it a
form of speech to exaggerate their size
or is it a literal description Yeah.
Yeah. I wouldn't say it's literal what
what they're they're trying to say that
these guys were very tall. These guys
were humongous. That's
what about them exactly though. What
What's the question about the giants
specifically?
What what I'm trying to say is that a
lot of times people look at the Bible
and say, "Look how evil these these God
used to send out these Israelites and
make them kill all these people." What I
think a lot of the the cultures that the
Israelites were fighting were were were
were um fallen were fallen beings. Yeah,
that's an assumption that you probably
got from Michael Heiser. That's not
necessarily the case because you're
going to have to assume because that's
one of his arguments. You're going to
have to assume that after the flood,
another influx of spirit beings
impregnated women to produce these
giants. What scriptural basis do you
have for that assumption?
that uh that these guys were um um
because you're assuming that the neph
let me help them understand what you're
trying to say. The reason why God
ordered the Israelites to wipe out the
Canaanites is because they were giants
meaning the hybrid the offspring of the
sons of God, these spirit creatures with
women. And so it makes sense that God
would want to eradicate them because
they were not generally human. They were
a hybrid, a corruption of angelic seed
and human seed. Well, that's true before
the flood. What proof do you have that
after the flood, another influx of
spirit beings came and impregnated
women?
That's a that's a good question. And the
only way you can have I don't think the
Bible really gets into that, but the
only way you can um explain that more
into detail, I mean,
I mean, I don't know if you believe or
follow this book, but they said that the
uh book of Enoch, right? Yeah. the the
the descendants of the sons of God were
killed in the flood. And Enoch intimates
that what we call ghosts or demons are
actually the spirits of the hybrid that
when they were killed, their spirits
roam around as demons. Well, number
one, even if that's the case, that's pre
flood. So, what evidence do you have
after the flood that another influx of
spirit creatures impregnated females to
produce another a race of giants. Number
two, the New Testament does not identify
the demons as the spirits of the hybrid
who were destroyed in the flood. That's
an extra biblical source that can be
true or can be false because not
everything in Enoch is correct. So, we
use that which is inspired and canonical
to determine those parts of Enoch that
are true or false. And thirdly, the
assumption is, this is what I want you
to pay attention to, that in Genesis
6:4, the Nephilim are the hybrid, the
descendants of the sons of God who got
the women pregnant, as opposed to being
another group of creatures that were
there when the offspring of the sons of
God were
born. If you read Genesis 6:4 carefully,
it does not say the Nephilim were their
offspring. It says there were Nephilim
in those days and afterwards when the
sons of God went into the daughters of
men and had children with them. So you
have two groups there. The Nephilim and
the children sired by the sons of God.
You're assuming they're one and the
same. And grammatically you can argue
that or you can just allow the plain
reading of the text to lead you to
assume they're two different groups of
beings. Reread it. Too many assumptions
being read into the passage. And it's
not your fault. Say that again. I'm
sorry. I'm sorry, Sam. Say that last
part. They're two sets of what? Two sets
of beings. The Nephilim and the children
of the sons of God. They're not one and
the same. It doesn't say that in Genesis
6:4. Read it. Oh, yeah. I agree. I agree
completely. So, but then let's go back.
If you agree that the Nephilim, the
giants are not necessarily the offspring
of the sons of God, these spirit
creatures. They're not the hybrid
offspring of angels and
humans.
Then, Nephilim are simply human beings
are excessively large. They arise from
the human gene pool. And in fact, if you
read who the Nephilim were in the time
of Canaan, they actually would have come
from the line of Ham. They were human
descendants of Ham.
Um, okay. I I I didn't really understand
what uh now I understand what you're
saying. Well, I because your assumption
is that the giants are the offspring of
the sons of God, right?
The giants are the sons of God, but I
also believe that um well, the the sons
of God, which are the the fallen angels
that that Okay. Do you believe the
Nephilim are the the offspring of the
fallen angels? Yes. Show me where it
says that in Genesis 64. But I also
believe that they they continued even
after the flood. Where does it say in
Genesis 6:4 that the Nephilim are the
offspring of the fallen angels. That's
my point. Show it to me. The text is
right there. It doesn't say that. Reread
it. Reread it carefully.
It says there were giants in the earth
in those days and also after that when
the sons of God so they were around when
the sons of God did this, right?
Sorry. They were around when the sons of
God did what they did. Read it. It
doesn't say they are the offspring. It
says the giants were there when the sons
of God did what they did. Get women
pregnant and had children with them.
Read it. It's right there. Doesn't say
that they are the offspring.
Okay. So, if I say, "Hey, I was around
here. Let me give you a modern example.
Let me give you what I'm saying. If I
was around, if I say I was around when
the angels slept with the women and had
children, are you going to assume that
I'm one of the children?"
No. Okay. But that's what the text says.
The Nephilim were there when this
phenomenon took place.
What phenomen? So, what's So, what's
your point? You're trying to say that
they're human beings. The clear the
plain reading of the passages, they're
simply human beings from the human gene
pool that were excessively large.
Because if you read carefully, Goliath
was one of the sons of Anak. He was a
giant. And by a giant, it meant he was
over 9 ft tall with six fingers and six
toes. That to them was a gigantic 9 ft
tall. So it is quite possible within the
human gene pool you can have a race of
excessively large humans as you can have
a race of excessively small humans
called dwarfs that has nothing to do
with an angelic influx infestation.
That's what I'm trying to say. Too many
assumptions. I know many Christians do
believe that. That's fine. But again
it's too many assumptions being read
into the text. It's not explicit.
So just just to summarize, you're saying
that the the the giants existed before
the
right. Yeah. And after But you're saying
that these particular giants, they they
were created by God. The angels, were
they created by God?
Yeah. Was Noah created by God? No. But
were these giants were these giants
produced uh by the angels or were these
giants produced by God himself? Even the
way you ask me the question is wrong.
It's like saying was Noah was Noah
produced by the angels or by God. Noah
was produced by his mother and father.
What are you talking about?
In one sense everything is produced by
God. Even the angels and their seed just
like I was produced by God but God
produced me through my mother and
father. So re rephrase your question so
I understand what you're asking me. No,
I'm okay. I'm trying to say that you're
you're saying that the giants existed
before the angels came down and had sex
with the daughters of men. That's what
the text says. The giants were there
when the sons of God came down and got
these women pregnant. So where did the
giants come from? The same place you
came from. You came from human parents.
They are human beings, descendants of
human beings. Okay, that's that's what
I'm trying to say. That's why when you
ask me, are they from angels from God?
That's a confusing way of of asking the
question. It's like saying okay am I
from God or am I from my mother and
father everything is from God but how
did God bring me into being through my
mother and father even those offspring
of the sons of God they too are from God
in that they wouldn't exist if God
didn't allow the angels to do what they
did nothing can happen no one can be
born nothing can be created apart from
God permitting it or decreeing it
right
okay awesome explanation you get what
I'm trying to say so much so what I'm
trying to say is before you swear by a
position and you cling to a position,
you need to hear all sides of the issue
and ask the Holy Spirit to guide you to
the truth and to protect you from error
because Proverbs 18:17 is a verse I want
you to remember. It says, "The first to
present his case seems right until
someone comes and questions him." So,
let me repeat Proverbs 18:17 again.
Proverbs 18:17. the first to present his
case seems right until someone comes and
questions him. So if you want to believe
the giants are the offspring of these
fallen angels, that's fine. But it's not
explicit. It's not conclusive. And not
everyone agrees with that
interpretation.
Interesting. Yeah, I'm not the only one.
I didn't invent this. Many scholars
don't agree with the interpretation that
the giants, the Nephilim, were the
hybrid offspring of the fallen angels
who cohabited with women.
So I mean I mean I understand what
you're saying but then you'll be saying
that there were two versions of the
giants. Yeah. If they're human beings
why are you shocked that you'll have
giants who are 9 ft tall before the
flood and giants that are 9 feet tall
after the flood. So you should be
shocked that Karim Abdul Jabbar is
walking around. I don't get your Yeah.
You get what I'm saying? Because that's
what I'm saying. I don't understand why
it is shocking. In our human DNA, we can
produce a race of giants that are 7
feet, 8 feet, 9 ft. Because if you look
at the dimensions of Goliath, he turns
out to be over 9 ft tall. He's not 20
feet tall.
And he is one of the giants. He's a son
of Anak. So why would that shock you
that there were tall people before the
flood, tall people after the flood?
There are tall people here. They're all
in the NBA. You gather all the NBA
players and here's your race of giants.
So let's exterminate them, wipe them
out.
But who's to say those guys are human?
I'm just kidding. I'm just kidding. I
don't know. No, you're right. Because
you know they say aliens do visit and
artificially inseminate people, right?
Yeah. Anyways, thank you so much. Good
questions, brother. Excellent questions,
man. Thank you for allowing me to
challenge you and sharpen you for the
glory of Jesus Christ. Thank you,
brother. Amen. God bless. Good
questions. This was asking question from
his